cameron was the ultimate example of a
human beer dove Cameron is still
mourning the loss of her friend and
former co-star Cameron voice in a new
interview with Seventeen magazine The
Descendants star reveals how she found
out the tragic news about Boyce who died
in asleep after complications with
epilepsy on July 6 he was selfless and
generous
he was magnanimous quote I had just
woken up early in a London hotel room to
the sound of my phone ringing off the
hook the 23 year old were called reading
the news in a text from her mom and she
says she immediately called her other
descendants co-star booboo Stewart we
just sobbed without speaking loved by
anyone would ever to experience his like
indescribable energy Dov revealed that
even before she worked with Cameron on
the Disney franchise she wanted to be
his friend I had always thought damn
what a charismatic bright and brilliant
kid don't you ever miss screaming at
people and just making them run away
from you you're thinking of my mother
and I was usually on the other end of
that so not really and when the two
finally met Duff said it was nothing but
love quote from that first day onward
Cameron was my friend and he treated me
like he treated everyone else like they
were the most important person in the
room she added I loved him like a
brother was always following his death
dub says that the cast has been leaning
on one another I think something like
this horrible loss makes you realize how
important you are all to each other
earlier this month ET spoke with
descendants three director kenny ortega
where he explained how he plans to carry
on Cameron's legacy everything that
Cameron's in he brings the light every
every room that he walked into every
cause that he that he did you know
pushed for and everything that he ever
did I mean he was it was impossible not
to be drawn into him that's how I found
him I fell in love with him when he was
doing Jessie and I
after him four descendants so
descendants three you know again we'll
just remind everybody of his incredible
gift you know he was bioluminescent he
was lit from the inside out he really
was and and we will miss him but we will
carry his legacy forward